das extrem wichtig zur Verteilung in
Europa denn alle europäischen
Innenminister haben beschlossen dass die
Ukrainer legal kommen können und sich
überall niederlassen und überall das
Recht haben zu arbeiten zu leben und die
Verteilung hat sich dann ergeben spontan
es gab ein lesefair und das stößt jetzt
an seine Grenze auf weiter stützen
glaube ich ne Herr Müller
den Menschen selber überlassen
die meisten Ukraine und das haben sie
selbst gesagt sie natürlich bei den
Nachbarn aber das ist jetzt in
Deutschland im pro Kopf
sind die höchsten Zahlen in molder in
Tschechien Tschechien hat
460.000 Anträge 11 Millionen Einwohner
hat alleine mehr Flüchtlinge aufgenommen
als es Bayern getan hat man kann die
Geschichte aber auch umgekehrt sehen
viel mehr aufgenommen
suchen denn es ist ja es gibt keinen
Innenminister in Europa auch nicht die
Ungarn niemanden der sagt wir wir stoßen
die Ukraine zurück da gibt's die werden
wenn sie fliehen müssen Sie versuchen zu
bleiben das ist ja das wichtige wenn sie
aber kommen dann wird es entscheidend
sein dass wir es schaffen eine
Ungleichgewicht das Frankreich Spanien
Italien zusammen weniger Ukraine
aufgenommen haben als das Tschechien mit
11 Millionen Einwohnern ist die Frage
wie kriegt man das ausgeglichen aber ich
will noch haben wir bei den
Sozialleistungen war der Vorwurf kam ja
auch von Herrn Nicolaidis die
Sozialleistung sein hier im Vergleich zu
hoch also deswegen ganz schnell einmal
die Fakten klar machen wie ist es in
Frankreich also in Frankreich ist es
tatsächlich so wer als ukrainische Frau
und Kind bekommen einige hundert Euro
Sozialhilfe aber für das Wohnen kommt
man auf 200 Euro und jetzt weiß ich
erstmal ich habe Frankreich jahrelang
gelebt in Paris aber überall in
Frankreich wenn man eine Mietvertrag
schließen will damit kann man nicht
mieten wenn man
viele die Frankreich als Ausländer
mieten müssen ein Jahr Kaution
hinterlegen also es ist unglaublich
kompliziert mit dem Geld kommt man nicht
durch was wir aber merken und das ist
das alleine der ist ja überall in Europa
wir haben das die Polen geschafft viel
mehr aufzunehmen pro Kopf aus
Deutschland weil die Bevölkerung
aufnimmt es nirgendwo auch in Warschau
gibt es nicht so viel organisierte
Quartiere kein Bürgermeister hat 10.000
oder 100 tausende freie Wohnungen die
einzige Chance dass in diesem Winter zu
schaffen und jetzt muss der Staat aber
auch etwas tun und ich ich weiß dass das
jetzt im Innenministerium angedacht wird
ich hoffe da kommen schnell
Entscheidungen dass man die privaten die
aufnehmen und das ist die Stütze hier
dass man die auch finanziell mit einer
dankespauschale wie das in England
funktioniert jeden Monat wir könnten 500
€. das kommt den Bund sogar billiger als
das komplizierte System also weg mit
Harz nicht mehr pauschal in das
harzsystem für ukrainische Flüchtlinge
sondern an diejenigen zahlen die
Familien aufnehmen ukrainische Frauen
und Kinder aufnehmen bei sich pauschal
weiß ich 400 € Zimmer man ganz schnell
der Praxis checkt würden sie das machen
finden Sie dass Sie sinnvoll Idee bin
jetzt keine innenpolitikerin dass man
denen denjenigen die Wohnraum zur
Verfügung stellen einen Obligo gibt es
oder in eine Unterstützung das ist auf
alle Fälle richtig denn es ist in der
Tat so dass der Raum begrenzt ist wir
sprachen ja gerade darüber das Gemeinden
jetzt auch wieder die Turnhallen öffnen
das was wir aus 2015 kennen und insofern
ist das eine Möglichkeit aber ja nicht
zusätzlich sagt der Klaus sondern
stattdessen
wenn er eine Familie Unterkunft hat und
für die Mutter mit Kind ist es ja viel
weniger kompliziert wenn Sie die meisten
wollen ja nur vier Monate bleiben über
den Winter die wissen ja planen jetzt
nicht ein Jahr hier zu wohnen und wenn
sie dann die Chance haben von einer
deutschen Familie oder von deutschen
aufgenommen zu werden die noch helfen
können das funktioniert
möglicherweise erstmal
gleichzeitig Anreize schaffen
meine Wahlkreis Bürger im Chiemgau und
im Berchtesgadener Land ja im Frühjahr
zu aufgenommen jede Menge großartig was
dafür eine aufnahmebereit aber die hat
nachgelassen jetzt habe ich aber nicht
nur bei in meinem Zimmer ganz allgemein
weil eben
Beobachtungen gemacht werden die die
Geduld der Leute der Bevölkerung in
Deutschland schon sehr strapaziert also
zum Beispiel das wollte ich sie ja
gerade fragen als das
migrationswissenschaftler ich habe mir
heute mal angeschaut die Reisetätigkeit
zwischen Deutschland und der Ukraine
was da an hin und her permanenter
Reiserei ist
ein Beispiel dieser Woche wenn Sie
klicken jetzt kommenden Freitag 2
Dezember fahren allein aus Berlin 32
flixbusse
zu Destination nach Kiew nur nach Kiew
davon sind 24 bereits ausgebucht und
endlich die Situation zurück aus zehn
Großstädten in Deutschland insgesamt ein
ähnliches Bild hinterlegt das wollte ich
denn wissen
ich glaube da muss man nur mit ein paar
dieser Ukrainerinnen reden die sind
getrennt von ihren Männern von ihren
Vätern von ihren Söhnen wenn Sie
volljährig sind dürfen sie nicht
ausreisen das ist ein Krieg die die
Männer dürfen nicht raus zwischen 18 und
64 aber da kann man als praktisch
zurückgefahren
beantworten das ist ja nicht eine
Situation wie in Syrien wo man sich vor
der Regierung fürchten muss man fürchten
sich ja nicht für ihre Regierung die
fürchten sich vor den Drohnen den Bomben
den Granaten und natürlich im Grunde
genommen müssten wir froh darüber sein
dass sehr sehr viele in den ersten
Wochen die größte Flüchtling Euro
Millionen in wenigen Wochen die gekommen
sind sehr sehr viele sobald es ging
sobald es wärmer würde zurückgefahren
sind und zu sehen können wir wieder in
unserer Wohnung sein und sehr viele sind
zurückgekehrt Millionen aber der Vorwurf
ist ja ganz klar von den Ramsauer
die ganz klare Frage
von Wirtschaftswissenschaften zu
Migration ich wollte das einmal ich
wollte das einmal ganz klar aussprechen
weil das Ziel ja in die Diskussion die
Herr März auch angetextet hat im übrigen
in dieser Sendung als er das Wort sozial
Tourismus genutzt hat was er
anschließend was er anschließen dann mit
der Entschuldigung zurückgenommen hat
frau Zimmermann also Herr Ramsauer liegt
die Reise Tätigkeit
über die Bevölkerung in seinem Wahlkreis
und sagt da gibt's eine Missstimmung und
man fragt sich warum diese Reise
Tätigkeit vorherrscht und der verknüpft
das mit der Diskussion um Sozialleistung
was ist denn ihre Antwort darauf also
können wir den Vorwurf können wir den
Vorwurf entkräften ich hätte gerne
heransauer Sprache sei so eine
Missstimmung zwischen und dann hat er
leider abgebrochen ich hätte es gern mal
konkret an dem Beispiel gehabt was sie
meinen um darauf zu sagen als Beispiel
gebracht
ich werde dann gefragt
wir sollen aufnehmen aber warum wird da
diese starke Reise Tätigkeit
getätigt warum werden die hohen
Sozialleistungen gewährt noch Hartz 4
warum kommentiert dann ins Bürgergeld
hinein dann also
Antwort ja das sage ich dann immer das
sind berechtigte Fragen bitte beachten
Sie wir sind in der Opposition wir haben
das nicht zu bestimmen doch das ist
Argumentation ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
und jetzt wieder in der Opposition wir
können das alleine nicht stören dann
sagen die Leute ja aber wir werden doch
irgendwas immer noch Einfluss haben und
sagt mir selbstverständlich wir tun
unsere Möglichkeit zum
Beispiel den Kompromiss beim Bürgergeld
jetzt herbeizuführen mit den Elementen
die sie ja alle kennen gesprochen
im Moment mit den Zahlen an mittlerweile
rund 1,2 knapp 1,3 Millionen ukrainische
Flüchtlinge also was wäre ihre Lösung
die Leistung wegnehmen zu sagen wir
haben eine Obergrenze plötzlich also was
sagen sie den Menschen im Berchtesgaden
gemacht gerade gemacht hat die Ursache
allen Übels muss man natürlich angehen
und ich gehöre auch zu denen die sagen
muss im Verhandlungen eintreten wie auch
immer das mache es gegen meine eigenen
Parteilinie sein und gegen manchen
Draufgänger auch in meiner Fraktion der
am liebsten auch noch kampfschutz
liefern möchte da bin ich direkt dagegen
ich bin auch direkt dagegen dass Waffen
mit offensiv Charakter geliefert werden
die auf Russisch ist auf echtes
russisches Gebiet schießen können
Bindestrich nichts dagegen und eine das
selenski hat das letzte Woche gefordert
selensky hat es gefordert Gefahren
keinerlei Zusagen aber ich meine wenn
die Diskussion liebe Frau Zimmermann
aufkommen ich wäre nein ich bin gar
nichts durcheinander ich sage ja nur
nein die Richtung Russland
abgefahrenski ich habe doch gerade
erklärt selensky hat das gefordert und
wenn der sowas fordert dann kommt der
schnell bei uns so eine Diskussion im
Gang wie weit kann man gehen ich wollte
ja nur sagen ich wollte nur ich wollte
ja sagen ich gehöre nicht zu denen die
Richtung Draufgängertum gehen sondern zu
denjenigen die sagen jetzt muss
irgendwann mal fahren
schon gesagt
ein bisschen
und auf Seiten hier von Lafontaine zu
reden miteinander und am Ende zu sehen
was kommt dabei raus und dann beginnt
Verhandlungen entsteht immer ein
Waffenstillstand
setzen wieder von Heizungen von Energie-
gleichzeitig auch aus kalafontaine das
hatten wir in der Geschichte auch noch
nicht so oft CSU in diesem Fall
zumindest Peter Ramsau und Oskar
Lafontaine auf einer Linie gegeben